The topic of this recitation
is election forecasting,
which is the art and
science of predicting
the winner of an election
before any votes are actually
cast using polling data
from likely voters.
In this recitation, we are going
to look at the United States
presidential election.
In the United
States, a president
is elected every four years.
And while there are a number
of different political parties
in the US, generally
there are only two
competitive candidates.
There's the
Republican candidate,
who tends to be
more conservative,
and the Democratic candidate,
who's more liberal.
So for instance a recent
Republican president
was George W. Bush, and a
recent Democratic president
was Barack Obama.
Now while in many countries
the leader of the country
is elected using the
simple candidate who
receives the largest number of
votes across the entire country
is elected, in the
United States it's
significantly more complicated.
There are 50 states
in the United States,
and each is assigned a
number of electoral votes
based on its population.
So for instance, the most
populous state, California,
in 2012 had nearly 20 times
the number of electoral votes
as the least populous states.
And these number
of electoral votes
are reassigned
periodically based
on changes of populations
between states.
Within a given state
in general, the system
is winner take all in the sense
that the candidate who receives
the most vote in that state
gets all of its electoral votes.
And then across
the entire country,
the candidate who receives
the most electoral votes
wins the entire
presidential election.
Now while it seems like a
somewhat subtle distinction,
the electoral college versus
the simple popular vote model,
it can have very
significant consequences
on the outcome of the election.
As an example, let's look at
the 2000 presidential election
between George W.
Bush and Al Gore.
As we can see on the
right here, Al Gore
received more than 500,000 more
votes across the entire country
than George W. Bush in
terms of the popular vote.
But in terms of
the electoral vote,
because of how those
votes were distributed,
George Bush actually
won the election
because he received five more
electoral votes than Al Gore.
So our goal will be to
use polling data that's
collected from likely
voters before the election
to predict the
winner in each state,
and therefore to
enable us to predict
the winner of the
entire election
in the electoral college system.
While election prediction has
long attracted some attention,
there's been a
particular interest
in the problem for the
2012 presidential election,
when then-New York
Times columnist Nate
Silver took on the
task of predicting
the winner in each state.
To carry out this
prediction task,
we're going to use some data
from RealClearPolitics.com that
basically represents polling
data that was collected
in the months leading up to
the 2004, 2008, and 2012 US
presidential elections.
Each row in the data
set represents a state
in a particular election year.
And the dependent variable,
which is called Republican,
is a binary outcome.
It's 1 if the Republican
won that state
in that particular
election year,
and a 0 if a Democrat won.
The independent
variables, again,
are related to polling
data in that state.
So for instance, the Rasmussen
and SurveyUSA variables
are related to two
major polls that
are assigned across many
different states in the United
States.
And it represents the
percentage of voters
who said they were
likely to vote Republican
minus the percentage
who said they
were likely to vote Democrat.
So for instance, if the variable
SurveyUSA in our data set
has value -6, it means
that 6% more voters
said they were likely
to vote Democrat
than said they were likely to
vote Republican in that state.
We have two additional
variables that
capture polling data from
a wider range of polls.
Rasmussen and SurveyUSA are
definitely not the only polls
that are run on a
state by state basis.
DiffCount counts the number
of all the polls leading up
to the election that predicted a
Republican winner in the state,
minus the number of polls that
predicted a Democratic winner.
And PropR, or
proportion Republican,
has the proportion of all
those polls leading up
to the election that
predicted a Republican winner.